[Music]
foreign
welcome to Sky News breakfast I'm
Jonathan Samuels and we start with a
growing number of countries introducing
covid restrictions on Travelers arriving
from China last night the us became the
latest to say all the rivals from China
will have to provide a negative test
result but the UK government has said it
currently has no plans to follow suit
well it all comes after doctors in China
reported that some hospitals are
overwhelmed by the numbers of people
dying from covid despite the country
recently easing its tough restrictions
on the United States India Italy Japan
and Taiwan South Korea and Malaysia said
they will now require covet tests for
travelers from China
among the countries who say they will
not oppose impose additional
restrictions on travel for now are the
UK Germany Thailand Australia as well
we'll continue to monitor the
circumstances that are occurring in
China and in other parts of the world as
well as we do we'll take the appropriate
advice from the health experts and
follow that advice there's no change in
the travel advice at this point in time
but we're continuing to monitor the
situation as we continue
to monitor the impact of covert here in
Australia as well as around the world
our priority is to keep Australians as
safe as possible
the Australian prime minister there
joining me now is our Asia correspondent
Cordelia Lynch and as we were just
saying Cordelia there's uh quite a
disparity isn't there between different
countries and their approach to this
this stage there is a big Gulf we see
America and Italy uh testing those
arriving from China immediately those of
course are two countries that face the
full force of covid-19 in the first
outbreak back in 2020 but we have UK
saying they are not going to reintroduce
covid-19 restrictions now we may see
this change though in the days and weeks
to come it's a fluid situation the
situation in China is that it has
decided to open up in part uh we think
really from political pressure it is no
longer publicizing uh it's covid-19
rates its death toll either in some of
the hospitals we've been speaking to in
northern China are certainly Under
Pressure this is a country with a low
vaccination rate and we're seeing the
elderly becoming particularly sick in
the Lunar New Year as well we're going
to see Chinese Travelers potentially in
the countryside returning with covered
cases there is a real worry in China
about a further outbreak and a potential
death toll with a health infrastructure
that is struggling with this but look
this is a world where people are Keen to
move on not to be yet again hampered by
covid cases and the travel restrictions
that were enforced on them previously so
at the moment UK is standing their
ground not moving but others not willing
to take that risk
Cornelia thank you
I just want to update you on Ukraine
with some breaking news that we've had
in the last few minutes a Ukraine
official has reported a new wave of
Russian missiles hitting Kiev one Blast
has been heard in the capital but the
president's office says more than a
hundred missiles were incoming across
the country it comes as Russia's foreign
minister Sergey lavrov has rejected
Vladimir zelenski's peace formula as a
basis for negotiations lavrov said
Cube's idea of driving Russia out of
eastern Ukraine and Crimea with Western
help was an illusion so breaking news
the Ukraine official has reported a new
wave of Russian missile attacks this
morning on Kiev at least one Blast has
been heard in the capital we will of
course keep across the situation in
Ukraine throughout the morning for you
foreign
strikes in the new year as the new boss
of the TUC says the government is
sabotaging efforts to resolve them I'm
going to speak to him at half past eight
uh get his thoughts right now though
let's speak to our political
correspondent Mari Aurora who's in
Westminster I mean many people will be
thinking this sounds a little bit like a
potential general strike
it really will Jonathan I think in some
ways this could potentially escalate to
a situation where it's a general strike
in everything apart from name
essentially but I think it would be
interesting to see how Paul Nowak speaks
to you this morning so we've got that
interview 8 30 on Sky News and he's
going to be speaking to you about these
strikes and the industrial action I
think we can expect him to realistically
criticize the government's response to
the strikes and the fact that they're
still not budging on pay I think we can
expect that from him I think we can also
expect him to comment on as you say
those uh rumors those those potential
suggestions from certain union bosses
like Mark sawalka yesterday who told Sky
News there was potentially going to be
some level of synchronization or
coordination between several unions on
strikes to try and team up and maximize
disruption so I think we can expect him
to comment on that as well and also
obviously we can expect him to defend
workers and the fact that they are
striking I mean this morning
Paul Nowak sorry he said that striking
workers have been left with absolutely
no choice as as to striking after 10
years of pay cuts and he's also accused
Ministers of sabotaging the efforts to
reach settlement so you know at the
moment the unions are really ramping up
the rhetoric they're really not dialing
down the rhetoric they're really ramping
it up and I think those uh those
tensions between the unions and the
government are only going to escalate
unless somebody decides to compromise
somebody decides to budge get around
that table and find a solution at the
moment it doesn't look like it's
possible the government are really
staying tight-lipped or on those Rises
and therefore so far they're not budging
okay Marion westmas thank you
a fire burning through a Cambodian hotel
casino on the board with Thailand has
killed at least 10 people local police
say at least 30 people are injured the
fire broke out at around midnight at the
Grand Diamond Casino and Hotel in
papetti
there was an extraordinary rescue when
two people were seen hanging onto the
jib of a crane as a way of escaping the
building the arm was moved away from the
hotel and lowered so the people rescued
could climb down to safety
houses have been encased in ice Millions
have lost power and at least 65 people
have now died during the bomb Cyclone
that's been battering large parts of
North America even as the weather eases
disruption continues to mount more than
20 000 flights have been canceled in the
United States since the 22nd of December
that's according to FlightAware as many
as 1.8 million properties were without
power across the U.S although Services
have now been restored in most areas New
York State the hardest hit region will
receive federal support after President
Biden approved an emergency declaration
and in the City of Buffalo the National
Guard has been drafted in to enforce a
driving ban ensuring the only vehicles
on the roads are those of the emergency
services our U.S correspondent James
Matthews reports
this is how cold it's been these are
houses Frozen on the shores of Lake Erie
a street in ice sculpture
the temperatures have taken their toll
across North America
the reach of this bomb Cyclone has
extended across thousands of miles and
several days it has gripped millions of
people
Upstate New York continues to struggle
through the effects of this human
tragedy they are still counting its
victims
Casey macaron lost her mother on
Christmas Eve after she'd gone outside
in freezing conditions in the City of
Buffalo
Monique Alexander was later found dead
in the street partially buried in snow
she was a hustler she was a caretaker in
the City of Buffalo heavy machinery has
been brought in for Roadside Rescue
while police in force a driving ban
nothing and no one is going anywhere
quickly it's been tough because the
driving ban is still in effect for the
City of Buffalo and so we haven't really
left our house in about a week I know
most of the stores that have been open
they have not been able to get new
deliveries of any goods and so if people
are able to go to corner stores or
supermarkets that have been reopening
the shelves are bare
fatalities have included people found in
their homes and stranded in their
vehicles there is a state of emergency
but there's anger at the State of
Affairs in Erie County one arm of local
government is blaming another mayor's
not going to be happy to hear about it
but storm after storm after storm after
storm the city unfortunately is the last
one to be opened and that shouldn't be
the case
it's embarrassing tell you truth and if
we have to working with the state we
will find a way to get through these
storms quicker by taking over operations
if need be I know the mayor's probably
not thrilled to hear it I don't care
anymore I want it done did you buy it
did you buy it all right put it back put
everything back come on there have been
numerous reports of looting
these are pictures from a supermarket in
Buffalo
it is grim here and it isn't over
as temperatures pick up there are
dangers presented by this snow melting
in these quantities as they dig
themselves out they are digging in for
the prospect of floods to follow
James Matthews Sky News Washington
well the UK is going to feel the effects
of the U.S bomb Cyclone that's been
battering parts of America as we've just
seen the Met Office has issued a yellow
weather warning for heavy rain in parts
of Scotland it's in effect from tomorrow
let's get more on this from our
meteorologist Joe Wheeler who joins us
now uh good to see you again Joe and it
does often happen doesn't it that we
tend to get the effects of big weather
events in the United States sometime
later and that's going to happen again
is it but not not snow and ice but more
wet weather
yes indeed in fact weather impacts on
weather right across the world because
driving every weather system we've got
the jet stream and really what's
happened with this winter storm is that
it's given a real bump to the jet stream
and that's going to drive these low
pressure systems towards us so you've
got two things going with the American
storm first of all those incredibly low
temperatures minus 40 degrees celsius uh
rarely seen in a lifetime and not only
that but very cold airs tank a long ways
southwards down towards Florida now of
course by that time it's running into uh
very mild air very warm air indeed and
that is what's driving the jet stream so
really the temperature gradient has just
made that jet stream stronger and
stronger and so this is where we start
to feel the impact because the jet
stream then starts pushing these weather
systems towards us and quite vigorously
as well so in fact over the next few
days for us it's looking changeable uh
we're going to see showers longer spells
of rain but along with that also some
very strong wins and everything is
moving through really quite fast and in
between you get these periods of
slightly colder conditions as well so
yesterday we saw just over 13 degrees
Celsius which is pretty impressive for
December around 55 degrees Fahrenheit
today that higher we're likely to see is
only around 9 or 10 degrees Celsius and
then we'll start to see the um the mild
conditions coming back but yes this rain
that comes through in the early hours of
tonight likely to be quite impactful the
parts of Scotland uh Northwestern parts
of England and again it's going to be
accompanied by these winds gusting to 45
even 50 miles per hour and of course
well we've had not only recent rain but
also some snow runoff there is a risk
there of some flooding
okay Joe in Lincolnshire thank you so
I'm just beginning to come up in
Lincolnshire thank you very much now
smoking is proving to be a hard habit to
break cancer research UK is now warning
of a million more cancer cases by 2040
if nothing changes they're also calling
for consultation to raise the age of the
sale of tobacco you may remember adverts
like these from a few years ago
every 50 barrettes you smoke will cause
a mutation
if you could see the damage you'd stop
oh gruesome aren't they those adverts
well according to cancer research UK
data up to 2018 showed the government
was seven years off track from meeting
its 2030 smoke-free Target the latest
data suggests if recent Trends continue
the target will now not be met until
2039
and while smoking rates are declining in
order to reach this goal smoking rates
need to drop around 70 faster failure to
do so could lead to around a million
cancer cases in the UK between now and
2040 our correspondent Matthew Thompson
is with me now in the studio Matthew a
lot of people are thinking aren't they
this time of year about New Year's
resolutions perhaps giving up smoking
finally 2023 is the year it's going to
happen
but it does need to happen doesn't it
and according to to This research
probably quicker than it is yes and it's
certainly not happening fast enough if
this cancer research UK report is to be
believed they actually mentioned New
Year's resolutions in it it's as good a
time as any to be talking about stopping
smoking but frankly the government are
not uh anywhere near their own stated
Target that is of keeping England
smoke-free or getting England smoke-free
by 2030. it was a Target set in 2019
it's defined as having five percent of
the population smoking incidentally
currently the latest figures we had from
about 2019 suggests that the figures are
about 14 at the moment they are dropping
but they're not dropping fast enough
cancer research UK says that that on
current trends it will not hit its
Target until 2039 so nine years later
than is currently the set government
Target you might remember in the summer
there was a review by Dr Javid can the
can review into precisely this issue it
found that commissioned by the
government incidentally it found that
the government was seven years behind
targets the implication from today's
figures is that that Target is slipping
yet further from the summer you might
also remember the can review implemented
a couple of recommendations the headline
one of which was to increase the age of
being able to purchase tobacco from 18
by one year every year until such time
as no one in the UK can actually buy any
tobacco the government has yet to
respond to that review in any way and so
cancer research UK is saying today that
they need to do so ASAP cancer research
UK says incidentally that the cancer is
or smoking is the leading cause of both
cancer and prevent deaths in the UK
around 500 000 Hospital admissions every
year are attributable to cancer so
clearly
stopping people smoking is a major kind
of a major impact on public health
cancer research UK says that it's not
going fast enough in principle the
government has committed to reducing
smoking in England in practice they're
lagging slightly they have sent us a
statement which we should read to you
they say that the government remains
committed to its smoke-free ambition by
2030 and the action we're taking means
smoking rates in England are at an
all-time low they say that they are
considering those can review
recommendations that I mentioned and
they will set out their next steps in
due course okay Matthew thank you for
that
uh let's take a look at some of the
day's other news now and police are
still questioning two men over the
murder of 23 year old Cody Fisher at a
nightclub in Birmingham Cody was
celebrating Christmas with his friends
at the crane nightclub when he was
stabbed a 22 year old man has been
arrested in the Midlands and a 21 year
old man held in London on suspicion of
murder for friends of the footballer
laid flowers at the scene saying they're
struggling to process what happened
just the impact it's had on myself
family friends I mean obviously me and
Kelsey are part of a friendship Group
which has a hole now that can't be
filled
um I was out the night it happened
and it hit me like a ton of bricks
um like I said he just had an infectious
smile
A Love For Life his friends his football
his family and he just tragic just
horrendous really really horrible and uh
just I know for me it's it's that I
can't get scripture at the minute
Elon Musk has said he believes his Tesla
car firm will be the most valuable
company on Earth that's despite its
shares losing 70 percent of their value
this year over falling demand for
electric cars and his problems at
Twitter
the family of rapper Theophilus London
have filed a missing person's report
they say he hasn't been seen for months
the musician's family and friends
believe that someone last spoke to him
in July in Los Angeles he was last
spotted in the skid row area in October
to China where there's been a huge
pileup of at least a hundred cars at
least one person died in the crash the
accident happened in thick fog with cars
and trucks piling into each other and
eventually stacking up on top of other
vehicles it all happened on a bridge in
the Chinese city of shenzhou many people
were trapped inside their vehicles
before Emergency Services were called to
the scene just terrifying
now firefighters could go on strike over
pay after the firefighters Brigade Union
said they're facing in work poverty
whilst bosses are being paid up to six
times more than an ordinary firefighters
wage while the union has already
rejected a five percent payoffer the
ballot result is due at the end of
January I'm joined now by the fbu
general secretary Matt rack a very good
morning to you uh so our firefighter is
going to go on strike do you think good
morning well we're in the middle of a
ballot as you say it's a secret ballots
I won't know the results of that until
the end of January but all the
indications are there's a huge amount of
anger out there among our members that's
this isn't just this year this is 12
years of stagnating pay driven by
central government unfortunately but
also by fire service employers and Fire
Chiefs and we keep being told to tighten
our belts like workers across the
country and firefighters are telling us
they've had enough they are struggling
to pay the bills and that's why we've
ended up in the city situation with us
Palatine unfortunately for industrial
action people are not prepared to take
this any longer and they're telling us
they want to fight back is it
responsible for a key emergency service
to go on strike
well of course nobody wants to go on
strike nobody joins the fire service to
go on strike but at the end of the day
people have to pay the bills and
it comes to Breaking Point and we have
people as you've reported in some cases
even using food banks reported by their
own employers that that's happening is
acknowledged that pay has fallen
significantly year after year real wages
falling and eventually people have to
look after their families and the
government needs to step in put money
into public services including the fire
service to provide decent funding for
decent pay to stop living standards
falling I was just looking at the the
figures once fully qualified
firefighters basic salary in London will
increase to 38 340 to 39
325 pounds per annum the average salary
is that right the average salary in the
UK 38 600. just just you you need to
compare apples with apples it's the
basics of a statistical honesty you're
using you're conflating London figures
with national figures the national
figure for a competent firefighter is 32
000 pounds a year that's the salary of a
competent firefighter after several
years of training so you're using
incorrect figures so coaching the London
figures uh 39 325 in that case in that
case you would need to compare the
London figure with the London wage
wouldn't you rather than completely so
there's not a lot of difference
let me finish let me finish you've asked
a question you've asked a question if
you're going to compare a London salary
of a firefighter you need to compare it
with the London salary of an average
which work and that's not what you're
doing you're twisting the facts get your
facts right if you're going to ask
questions
okay you tell me what the figures are
then because the figures on your website
say that this is this is from your
website it says 39 325 pounds is what a
a qualified fast Fighters basic salary
from our website the competent
firefighters wage in the UK is 32
244 pounds so I don't know where you've
got your figures from okay well let's
talk about what the government says
because the government says that if they
give a double-digit pay rise it's going
to fuel inflation even further and that
is going to make the cost of living
Christ last even longer well this is
just nonsense because there is no
evidence that the pay of public sector
workers has caused inflation whatsoever
so instead of Simply repeating
government spin to people you should
look at the facts inflation has been
caused by factors far outside our
control our members as other workers
have had to be told for more than a
decade to tighten their belts while the
richest people in this Society get
richer and richer corporations make
bigger and bigger profits the government
just a few weeks ago was willing to hand
out 45 billion pounds in tax cuts to the
wealthiest in society but tell working
people that they need to tighten their
belts and their families just have to
make do that's simply not acceptable and
millions of people across the country
are saying is not acceptable that's what
lies behind our disputes and the other
disputes that you're seeing across the
country yeah I talk about those disputes
the General Secretary of the pcsu says
it's a matter of time before we see
synchronized strikes is that something
you'd support
well if people are facing a common uh
attack which is on their living
standards why would they not work
together to try and force that attack
back so yes we will talk to other unions
we're in a dispute for ourselves which
is about firefighters pay with our
employers and the funding necessary for
the government to uh to to resolve that
but other workers are in a very similar
position and yes of course workers talk
to each other and trade unions talk to
each other it's simply common sense
is it not a theater that you'll lose
public support if we have a situation
that is essentially a general strike
won't the public get get seriously fed
up well I think the experience we've got
is that millions of ordinary people
across the country are sick and tired of
the richest people in society we're
given uh dodgy contracts during covid
tax cuts and seeing the profits of big
corporations boosted year after year
after year while Ordinary People are
told there is no money for them it's
simply a ludicrous during the pandemic
our members and others were called covid
Heroes they were clapped by the prime
minister they kept essential Services
going and as soon as that crisis begins
to ease we're told there's no money for
any rewards and that people need to take
further pay cuts how long should people
carry on taking pay cuts is simply
nonsense and it's not acceptable
okay uh we must leave you there the
results of that ballot Matt you did say
end of January was it 30th of January
yeah okay we'll find out more uh then uh
for now Matt rack from the fbu thank you
very much thank you
good morning welcome back you're
watching Sky News breakfast now millions
of adults with health problems and
struggling with the cost of living
crisis are living in cold and damp homes
new figures show more than 9 million
people are affected this month alone
with some conditions so bad even their
clothes are moldy a sky-sided charity
reports I've got a heater there which
again is obviously expensive but I try
and use that to help the problem there's
an electric dehumidifier there there's
two more chemical dehumidifiers down the
side so I've got a whole Army of things
to try and solve the problem nothing
short of an army will do for the battle
Jonathan is up against at home look
around his flat and all you see are rows
of dehumidifiers and what I discovered
this morning was that actually my closer
started to mold as well it spreads fast
especially when it's cold
thing that's causing the whole problem
is the Incredible cost of electric
heating we don't have gas central
heating here we only have electric
heaters and that means it's very hard to
heat very expensive and also you get
bigger problems with mold
millions of adults across the UK who
have pre-existing serious health issues
are living in similar conditions data
released today shows that 18 of the
population live in cold damp homes
and for a quarter of people with health
conditions their illnesses are made
worse by cold and damp because they
can't Heat their homes to a safe
standard
the department for leveling up housing
and communities says we are providing
cost of living payments worth twelve
hundred pounds to the 8 million most
vulnerable families to help this winter
this is in addition to capping People's
Energy bills this winter and next
that funding isn't new and according to
campaigners it leaves many people out
for those people like Jonathan
um who are struggling on electric only
heaters the cost of lifting them out of
fuel Poverty of them being able to heat
their home to an acceptable standard is
much higher so they are they will need
much more support to help them
um stay warm this winter I can see some
under there so I'll zap it with my
bleach and rub hard
and like some of it kind of rubs off but
then the bleach kind of does its work in
the next hour or so so in like an hour
that bleach would have kind of killed
off that bit
um and then tomorrow morning I'll find
another spot somewhere
it is simply Relentless Saudia Chaudhary
Sky News in buckinghamshire
now an Ohio police officer had a close
shave when a truck slid off a Motorway
in the deadly snow conditions in the U.S
dash cam footage shows the police
officer spotting the truck careering
down with control down the carriageway
jumped out of the way just in time the
truck slid on the ice smashed into his
patrol car but thankfully as you can see
there the patrol officer was unhurt
scary stuff let's get the weather here
in the UK
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
it's going to be unsettled this week
with further spells of wind and rain
that we are windy generally frost-free
start today with a scattering of showers
but Eastern Britain will be mostly fine
the morning will bring Sunny spells and
further blustery showers with the
showers mainly in the north and west and
wintry on Northern Hills it'll be
reasonably mild but still very windy
with Gales near western coast showers
will continue over northern and western
parts
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
now this year inflation reached over 11
its highest rates since 1981 and
although we may have passed the peak
households are continuing to feel the
squeeze and the country is still in the
grip of a series of strikes as we've
been reporting our economics and data
editor Ed Conway has unpicked the impact
of a year shaped by the cost of living
crisis and an ill-fated mini budget
2022 was a year let's have a look at
some of the charts that defined it
starting with perhaps the most striking
one of all this is inflation the
Consumer Price Index CPI this is the
annual rate basically prices going up
and have a look in October it got up to
11.1 percent that was the highest that
we've seen since going all the way back
to
1981 and the funny thing is when that
rises you get all sorts of other things
going on in the economy as well let me
put a line for strikes on top of it
we're just superimposing a different
line different access but look at how
similar the shapes are when inflation's
low you don't get as many strikes when
inflation's high you do tend to get more
strikes and that's exactly what we are
you know experiencing at the moment and
if passed is prologue that's also going
to push that red line up even further so
more strikes in the future now what is
it that's driving up prices where it's a
lot of things but above all it's this
gas prices wholesale gas prices and just
look at how low they were through 2007
2008 going all the way through to about
2021 so just before the of Ukraine it
got up really sharp and you can see on
the 26th of August in 2022 that is a
record the highest ever five pounds 50
thermos some people think it's going to
stay high for a long time longer even
than the government expects so important
thing uh there of course the consequence
of all of this is it goes into our
pockets doesn't it real household
disposable income is a really good
measure of just whether we're getting
better or for worse off so anything
above the line is getting better off
growth anything below the line is the
opposite and have a look at what
happened in 2022 look at the bars that
come up here look the biggest fall on
record you know that is why we're all
feeling a little bit more a little bit
worse off at the moment and that is
expected to continue in the coming years
as well final thing you couldn't really
talk about 2022 could you without
talking about the pound and about the
mini budget
um remember this is the pound against
the dollar anything above anything going
up is the pound getting stronger we're
going back through history 1985 the
plaza record up until recently the
lowest it ever got about one dollar uh
and five you've got black ones say that
wasn't a good moment for the government
of the Tory government as well you've
got 2016 the EU referendum look at these
big fours in the pound never really
recovered from there
but the nadir the real nadir was at the
mini budget I just thought the days
after the mini budget got to the lowest
level ever since the creation of the
dollar it's recovered since but some
people think it could Plumb those debts
again in the future it just goes to show
so many striking charts from 2022 I'm
sure there will be more in 2023 let's
hope it's more good news rather than bad
news Okay time then to take a look at
the papers and with us this morning
Sunday mirrors political editor Nigel
Nelson and Annabelle Denham the director
of communications at The Institute of
economic Affairs great to see you both
again this morning uh Nigel why don't
you kick off things for us this hour
we're going to speak to him actually um
at about half past eight the new boss of
the tucc he says workers are ready to
strike until the summer do you think the
public are prepared for that
well I mean so far the public seem to be
blaming the government rather than the
strikers for what's been going on it's
the fact that the government actually
won't sit down and talk to them
um and as you've seen from from Ed
Conway's rather excellent charts that
was we've sort of hit a perfect storm
here you've had
um a decade of real terms pay cuts which
just don't keep up with inflation
suddenly inflation starts soaring and
that's when you get get strike action
and it's reasonable to see how any of
this will actually get resolved unless
you're gonna you can get the uh get
ministers and the union sitting around
the table and thrashing out some kind of
settlement and what Paul Nowak is saying
is that according to their TUC research
that workers have lost an average of 20
000 pounds in real terms since 2008.
and now everyone's just had enough and
that's why you're seeing quite so many
sectors going on strike okay we'll get
more on that when we speak to him in the
next hour let's move on Annabelle to
um the times uh talking about Bank
closures I mean it's interesting from
personal experience I can't remember the
last time I went into a bank because I'm
so used to online banking now I can do
it all on there even paying checks
online
um and I suppose this is this this is
the sad inevitability
you're right Jonathan I think we've all
seen it we've seen bank branch closures
on our high streets as well as changes
in our own behavior as we move to
digital uh banking yes so this is a
story that's covered in a few newspapers
today that Britain's five biggest banks
have closed more than half of their
branches since 2015 after the number of
customers who are using them have has
collapsed so of course this is being led
by customer behaviors and Banks response
uh to that you know feeds integral cause
to the changing face of our high streets
which has been accelerated by the
coronavirus pandemic really interesting
data actually I read last month um about
how we've seen many high streets survive
through the pandemic despite some stores
closing vacancy rates remaining
reasonably uh stable but a change of use
of some of the premises particularly
from retail to cafes and restaurants and
bars opening but course there are
concerns there you've got a quote from
Alexander Stafford the conservative MP
um who's worried about financial
inclusion and justifiably so so I think
the government really is going to need
to address the fact that we're moving
towards uh cashless future and find ways
of giving as many people as possible
access to new technologies so that
they're not excluded okay we're going to
Rattle through these stories we're a bit
short of time this morning Nigel so
let's talk about eggs shall we I don't
know if you've had your boiled egg this
morning
um people will be thinking about
breakfast the course and this is all
about free range eggs
indeed and I hope to have my free range
eggs after we've done done the paper
review
um but apparently they're coming to an
end uh what it seems to have happened is
that uh Europe has changed the rules uh
which means that that
um a free-range egg is classified as
coming from a hen who is who has spent
no more than 16 weeks in a barn I have
to say I always thought they were just
pecking around outside that was the
whole point of it but anyway uh the
result is the EU will no longer have
this kind of 16-week margin and to keep
our Farmers competitive it means that
they must follow suit
um but it does it does seem to be a bit
disappointing that if you really do go
for free range eggs very shortly it may
be that's not what you're getting
okay well let's stick with the food
theme uh shall we Annabelle
um this is quite I mean this is quite
funny isn't it in a way
um chips crisps jam and wine aren't part
of my five a day I'm gonna some people
trying to keep themselves that they are
well yes and perhaps particularly so
over the festive season I certainly have
been indulging in plenty of crisps and
wine
um yes so this is research that suggests
uh almost one in ten britons do think
that
um the potatoes and crisps or the fruit
in Jam go towards that five a day Target
set by
um the public health uh bodies
um the NHS um you know that's a
surprisingly High figure though I
suppose it should be taken with a pinch
of salt as it's quite a small pole but
nonetheless analysis in that Daily Mail
story suggesting that only a third of
adults and 12 of teenagers in England
are eating those uh five fruits and
vegetables a day and the NHS is looking
at ways of addressing that creating a
new app called smart five day that will
track the amount of fruit and vegetables
that people eat and I suppose with
ongoing obesity levels
um as they are the NHS is going to have
to think of innovative ways of of
tackling that and and this is one of
them that seems reasonably sensible to
me so long as the cost isn't too high
yeah I mean Nigel will people really use
an app do you think to find that if
they're I mean if they already think
that a glass of wine is part of their
one over one a day do you think they're
going to be clever enough to be able to
use an app
no I think they're really in trouble
actually on the basis of that if you
reckon trips are actually good for you
uh and also the five a day thing I mean
surely people can count from one to five
so I think it's easy enough to know when
you've actually reached your five a day
limit
yeah good point
um uh the app called smart five a day
will tell users they're eating the right
portion sizes and the right Foods uh
Nigel Annabelle thank you once again